[Music]
this arc contains within it not only the
best chapter i've read from berserk but
perhaps the single greatest chapter or
most impactful i've read in my life
[Music]
while lost children felt like a brief
dewiggling of the main story the
conviction arc as a whole contains
within it not only a fascinating
continuation of the story but some harsh
truths and tough subject matter the
likes of which i've seldom seen explored
in this medium and certainly nowhere
near as tactfully executed this arc is a
special one and i want to do it justice
i'm totally not mark and today i want to
talk to you all about my experience
reading berserk's conviction arc for the
very first time
[Music]
normally when i tackle the series on my
channel i immerse myself into the
material wholly and entirely until such
time it's finished one piece almost six
months of nothing but one piece on my
channel jojo's bizarre adventure only
jojo for months and months and the same
can be said for dragon ball and even
hunter hunter but berserk is the first
series i've done where after every video
i'm forced to take a break for almost a
full month between sessions of reading
this is for logistical reasons as we
can't feasibly make videos using only
manga week in and week out but in turn
this created for me a relationship with
this story that i honestly couldn't have
predicted a reaction that with any other
manga would have conjured a resentful
disaster having to constantly pull
myself from material i'm outwardly
enjoying like naruto and dragon ball for
the express purpose of reacquainting
myself with this very dense and
emotionally draining series it seems
like it would be a recipe for disaster
and thus was the mindset i found myself
to be in every single time i have to
tackle this berserk series and i won't
deny this i want to be honest it's a
series that over the last few months has
forced me to stay off balance as i
switch from the comparably softer and
easier to understand material to
[Music]
child murder and complicated thematic
and symbolic orchestrations from a
master of his craft it's a lot of work
but every single time i grumpily pick up
these volumes for the purposes of making
a video and yet every single time they
without exception never allow me to put
them down they are some of the best
conceived works not only of a manga but
art that i've ever been exposed to it's
like the movie 51st dates only instead
of adam sandler berserk forces me to
fall in love with it every single time
and so i guess what i'm trying to say is
berserk is the 51st dates of manga and
on this occasion i was confronted by an
arc that reduced me to tears and a
chapter that shook my very soul and
unlike the previous berserk reviews
after finishing this arc i decided to
research a bit before i began writing
this time apparently the conviction arc
is broken up into three separate
sections lost children which i covered
last week binding chain and finally
birth ceremony the latter two will of
course receive the vast majority of the
focus in this video but through my
research i learned that quite a few
people don't like lost children which
was interesting to me but i think it's
understandable allow me to explain my
impressions of this divide and where i
think they stem from the black swordsman
arc i covered in my very first video was
unanimously seen as a decent start with
stunning visuals despite it being a
rather unremarkable start that would
eventually build up more steam towards
its conclusion similarly through my
coverage of the golden age arc i
recognized an almost global
acknowledgment of the story's
masterpiece status amongst manga from
both fans of the material to even those
that never even read berserk in their
lives however lost children was
different there was no such unanimous
agreements there were those that loved
it those that believed it was sort of
overrated and those that straight up did
not enjoy this section at all and while
i stand by my assessment of the story in
my last review that being i really
really liked it to put it simply i also
can see that i believe i know where
those sentiments of negativity are
stemming from golden age is a much more
standard format for a story with a fully
conceived narrative that follows the
life of one central character primarily
and his relationships with other key
characters as he grows into the men we
see today it's very much a coming of age
story not at all unusual because of this
we grow a fondness for this experience
and once it ends we want to see it
continue and unfortunately lost children
didn't offer an experience that many
were yearning for after golden age
despite it being an account that
followed the events of golden age and
black swordsman arcs respectively miura
decided not to tell a story that
primarily concerned itself with guts but
instead a little girl called jill gutz
plays a substantial role but certainly
not the central position instead acting
more of a supporting character in the
central plot thus resulting in lost
children feeling a little more like a
detour after golden age's epic
adventures rather than the continuation
a lot of people wanted personally i
viewed lost children as a much needed
break from the torment that was the
conclusion of the golden age arc and i
also found it to be a sound thematic
continuation of the series for sure
however i can absolutely see why this
wasn't what a lot of people wanted
conviction arc
during this portion of the story it
became clear relatively quickly that the
main storyline that took a break after
the golden age was once again picking
itself right back up during the events
of lost children we were introduced to
this impending religious force known as
the holy iron chain knights as one of
the forces on a mission pursuing and
capturing the black swordsmen and boy do
they do just that despite the high death
toll of their forces a new character by
the name of lady farnese and boy do i
have a lot to say about this girl she
secures one of the few victories over
guts in the series much to my amazement
there are of course a host of caveats to
this chance encounter but it's
compelling nevertheless keeping me
guessing the entire time as to how guts
would escape this exhausting situation
and in the end the answer was he
couldn't he was too beat up and as a
quick aside one aspect of the story that
immediately caught my attention was its
cast the story goes hard in the
character department and it's all for
the best let me tell you there's the
troubled commander of the holy iron
chain knights and religious devotee lady
farnese her devout protector and
all-around lovable badass in serpico the
horrifyingly accurate depiction of all
of religion's worst qualities in father
mosgas and many many more some of which
i'll touch on later for sure i loved
every single character in this arc and i
mean that without reservation i've no
idea what the consensus is with
characters like isidro or nina later on
who are designed to i think be a bit
more divisive but from an entertainment
and thematic standpoint i found them to
be pitch perfect however it's during
this time spent as a prisoner and after
escaping that i soon began to recognize
perhaps a parallel that miura was trying
to illustrate for me lady farnese is one
of the few main characters that stood
out among the holy iron chain knights
with her being the main character of
conflict for god's as well as his
eventual hostage once he escapes she's
complicated and in many ways horrible to
our main cast full of contradictions
both professionally and emotionally
physically and mentally weak yet
commander of her forces thanks to her
father espouses to the virtues of
dignity duty restraint and kindness and
yet relentlessly lashes out to others
with the smallest infraction oftentimes
with resentful or envious motivations
confidently religious but hedonistic and
confused she's one of the most
frustrating characters in the story
fundamentally flawed as a person and one
that plays a leading role receiving i
think the most development by far in
this tale and i absolutely hated her for
most of it but god damn it she's a
brilliant character now the only reason
i found it noteworthy to mention her
contributions this early in the arc was
due to the symbolic or nostalgic nature
of them she reminded me in some ways of
casca and okay okay i know what you're
thinking but hear me out for a second
for casca griffith may as well have been
her religion she devoted her life to him
and when it came down to choosing
between him and another she saw it sort
of like a sin almost going as far as to
kill herself in fact she tried to there
are of course a number of key
differences between these characters but
given that following lady farnace's
possession which has very similar
undertones and results by the way we're
immediately thrown back into contact
with kaska's storyline and due to that i
couldn't help but feel like this was an
intentional comparison being drawn on
behalf of miura oh and by the way with
this jump to casca's storyline almost
linking these two points of view we see
a
shared dream it's honestly hard to know
it's three pages and it depicts forces
that make themselves known later on in
the story upon his conclusion massive
beast death sickness desperation and a
white shining falcon in the middle of it
all a falcon that is shown as the desire
of this portrayed world i'm not sure in
retrospective if this was an omen
predicting what's in store during this
act or the next but lord knows almost
all of these come to fruition during
this portion of the story or its latter
half which oddly enough made me think
about the name of this arc conviction is
an interesting name for the story and
one that i didn't fully appreciate until
such time this part of the story rolled
around given the state of guts how far
gone he is and how the entire world
seems to be in some shape or form
interested in his capture i saw this
arc's title as an indication that he'll
be captured and in this story ultimately
convicted and while that does happen in
some shape or form in this series the
tale itself is more concerned with the
alternate meaning of the term conviction
which is a firmly held belief in
something and that brings me nicely to
my favorite chapter following guts's
first time returning to rickard godot
and casca in two years
cracks in the blade cracks in the blade
sits alongside campfire of dreams as
another one of the chapters that stand
out in my head is not just brilliantly
paneled but intensely profound taking
what we thought were known motivations
of the main character and turning them
completely on their head in campfire of
dreams it was his acknowledgement that
despite being among friends and there
being a home for him there he never felt
more alienated from those around him
reminding him that he needs to find his
own dream his own desires his own
convictions and within cracks in the
blade we finally get an answer to that
question posed during campfire of dreams
and with it yet another masterful
recontextualization of events from miura
just like campfire crax's most pivotal
moments center around two people sharing
insight having a heart-to-heart one
reflecting on lessons he learned in his
life and another about to make the same
mistake however unlike campfire cracks's
subject matter and philosophical
profundity casts a much broader net than
just within the arc it's presented and
in fact caused me to reflect on the
broader story and even certain decisions
i've made in my life it's a chapter that
works frankly as well as it does because
those that are reading it need to hear
it given most who read this manga are of
similar age to that of guts or at least
a little bit older and i can say many
stories have had that sort of impact on
me shining a light on the selfish
decision guts made to go out into the
world to leave kaska alone and to
embrace the hatred in his heart exacting
his revenge on the monsters that took
everything from him these are traits
often glorified in manga however with
berserk godot effectively caused guts a
coward that couldn't look sorrow in this
case kaska in the eye without wavering
someone who took the easy way out rather
than confront the problems and
prioritize the god the herculean figure
that guts has been made out to be due to
the feats he's enacted on those he's
hated now feeds into the narrative that
these are all acts of cowardice and it's
a brilliant way to look at this
particular problem and as a result of
that now he's beaten himself to near
death and cask has run off somewhere
presumably dead yielding massive
consequences for this arc and its
trajectory moving forward this is
exactly the sort of cause and effect i
was looking for from this story
following the golden age and it's
another example of a narrative decision
made by miura to further bolster his
claim to the title greatest mangaka to
have ever lived and i stand by that but
honestly i'm struggling to find the
words to effectively describe just how
steeped in philosophy and carefully
curated encounters the first half of
this section is taken into the context
of the current material all of the
criticisms of lost children a story i
once described as a fairy tale of sorts
echoes the criticisms goto had for guts
in the cracks in the blade chapter
claiming that he was indulging in a
fantasy instead of the reality being
there for those that he cared about one
of the many markers i think of a great
story is its ability to recontextualize
prior events and lend greater weight to
them via new material one piece does
this to great effect and i'm seeing it
right here too in berserk time and time
again
oh hi
i didn't see you there
i was just relaxing reading some anime
and enjoying a nice cup of nature's
sweetest beverage
when i wake up in the morning and look
at my beautiful wife fast asleep in her
boyfriend's arms i think to myself i
must do everything in my power to
provide for them and g fuel gives me the
energy to do just that aged in the
finest all-american plastic barrels for
upwards of 12 weeks to really bring out
the subtle tones of aromatic
undercurrents in every glass with
flavors like strawberry rainbow sherbet
blue ice shiny splash and even pewdiepie
tastes like a bridge now i'm not legally
allowed to say that gfu will make you
faster stronger more powerful than you
were before but
i will heavily imply it
g-fuel it's not about the taste
it never was
it's about the freedom to do as you
please and that's why
hey
what the hell are you doing in my house
is that my jacket
g-fuel break into your neighbor's home
this isn't a joke
let's talk about bellits and how they've
affected this story while staying in
line with the theme of this arc bravery
in the face of indulgent fantasy in the
black swordsman arc the count
exacerbated the situation he was in when
he wasn't capable of dealing with the
horrible fate that befell his wife in
the golden age griffith lost himself in
his own fantasy which in turn made his
journey that much longer ignoring
himself for the sake of one other person
that in the end he couldn't control in
lost children rosine couldn't deal with
her own personal life so she escaped by
killing her family and created her own
paradise free from the stresses of the
real world and the list goes on however
in this arc these themes are explored
more effectively through lady farnis
constantly pretending to herself that
the various horrific occurrences haven't
happened and that she remains the pure
good god-loving girl she wants to be
instead of the cold-blooded hedonistic
murderer she has been in the past
speaking of which let's talk about
father mosgas
the depiction of father mosgas as the
arbiter of god's will is one of the most
horrifying depictions i've yet seen from
this manga perhaps because he's paraded
around as a function of the church and
conceived of as a force of good his
design i think goes a long way in
reaffirming this unsettled approach that
i felt with it being far more simple and
expressionless than the other more
anatomically accurate depictions of the
human condition further making him feel
more other than any human we've come
across so far in the story shifting
gears for a moment from evil to innocent
comes the character of isidro i have no
idea what the prevailing opinion is of
this character online but i honestly
loved him i thought he offered a
reminder that innocence and childishness
is still very much alive in this world
and in the middle of these horrible
events i mean like puck said this story
would be too dark if they weren't there
with some additional surprising support
in the various tents and high stakes
action moments in a way he sort of feels
like a more standard shonen manga
protagonist but i think that coupled
with the nature of the story really had
me worried for him on more than one
occasion further building up the tension
in the scenes that he took part in i was
certain a brave kid like this wouldn't
be long for this world but every single
time his attitude and skills lifted him
out of the bad situations he found
himself in and i was relieved and hyped
because of it i also really enjoyed how
the aspects of isidro that kept him
alive and allowed him to remain in a
position of advantage or in fact his
readiness to accept reality and warp it
to suit him furthermore isidro pretty
much like guts fights against the idea
of fate or what is established he wants
to be the best version of himself and
sees guts as someone to aspire to be
like i honestly think he's pretty
awesome and i'm delighted that moving
forward we'll get to see more of him so
look okay at this point koska's alive
which is great but she's in the heart of
one of the worst situations in midland
and the center of what will be a dark
event unlike anything we've yet seen in
the story say for perhaps the eclipse
rest in peace everyone so let's see how
this one pans out nina orgies and the
cults peggy 18.
some of the imagery in this is
frightening and perhaps not for the
reasons you might be thinking when i was
in school history was my favorite
subject i always treated the lessons
like details stories of the past and one
of the topics that stunned me the most
was the black death a massive plague
that wiped out over half of europe which
to be honest is the clear inspiration
for this plague right here in midland
massive amounts of refugees living on
top of each other terrible living
conditions horrible hygiene widespread
poverty and hunger the imagery berserk
depicts routinely demonstrates some of
the absolute worst in humanity and i
think it's a wonderful means of creating
those heroic and triumphant moments we
remember in this series too which for
one reason or another leads us to this
hedonistic
cultist orgy never thought i'd say that
oh kinky
with the character of nina and her boy
toy to be clear i'd hate nina if not for
the fact that she's this way by design
i'm not supposed to like her what i do
find interesting about her though is
similar to lady fairness she has an
internal struggle coming to terms with
who she is and ought to be ethically and
that struggle is interesting given the
various strains this story puts her
through hashtag
she also introduces us to these cultists
which let's be perfectly honest creeped
me the [ __ ] out cultists that ironically
or unironically sought a similar
escapism to that of their religion
believing counterparts and because of
this they see koska as their new idol
after witnessing what happens when her
brand starts to bleed however this did
get me thinking because it seems like
contrary to guts to some degree the
demonic presences protect kaska rather
than attack her and well long story
short because of this most humans are
turned into zombies and mr goatman is
turned into an actual demonic entity the
likes of which will haunt my nightmares
forever alright but look i know what
you're thinking i glanced over something
speaking on the poetry and parallels of
these two opposing ideas colliding we
physically see them collide in the cave
as the holy iron chain knights arrive
and begin fighting these transformed
heretics it's total chaos everyone is
here puck flies as fast as he can to get
guts isidro snipes zombies with
unlimited rock ammo like the absolute
legend he is and kaska is
more vulnerable now than she ever has
been in the middle of absolute chaos and
destruction where the worst of the worst
both human and demon battle each other
the lost hurt and fragile caska is all
alone outnumbered by the hordes around
her and honestly
the way miora keeps distancing both guts
and casca is frustrating but at this
point it's just overwhelming it's
terrifying but in the middle of absolute
despair a faint but glimmering light
soars through the battlefield seizing my
attention momentarily suddenly a
familiar silhouette cloaked in black
flies across the page both portrayed at
the beginning as almost part of the
background and slowly thanks to some
expert paneling they shift to being the
focus of the fight and at the height of
the drama a surging black whirlwind
breaks through the tension stopping time
in its tracks for both sides and
confrontation and in an incredible panel
we finally see them guts and casca
reunited the background is neither
chaotic nor war torn just white and the
traces of what's happened outside of one
of the most intimate panels between two
misfortunate souls separated from the
rest of the conflict separated from the
rest of the world those who struggle
against this terrible fate are together
once again naturally and regrettably
this couldn't last and as casca is soon
apprehended and taken away to further
destruction much to guts's anger i
couldn't help but remark what a scene
the panel where they reunite is enough
to make you cry miura manages to
encapsulate all of the hurt relief and
struggle on gotz's single expression
contained on this one panel it's a
spectacular moment
oh
yes
oh my god this panel is so kino this is
more kino than anything serpico vs guts
the attempted escape from the chaos was
compelling and tense however this was
one of the smartest ambushes i've ever
seen committed to the pages of a manga
i'll keep it brief but this is certainly
like one of the best fights i've enjoyed
in the series applying knowledge we're
already familiar with the dutiful
protector of lady farnese combined with
precise placement for the battle
orchestrates one of the most respectable
one-on-one battles a character of his
standing has ever attempted against guts
and in doing so has immediately
catapulted him into the ranks of some of
my favorite humans from this series
knowing exactly where gutz's weak points
are and where his own shortcomings lay
placing himself on a narrow ledge
obstructing gutz's dominant hand and
preventing him from drawing his sword
are among just a few of the strategies
implemented in this altercation and the
best thing about this character is that
he doesn't take himself too seriously
he's often depicted in a much more
humorous manner than i've come to expect
from this series as antagonists and i'm
honestly a big fan and with him
providing the delay the holy iron chain
knights needed to whisk kaska away it's
the perfect recipe to bring all the main
players together for one final showdown
saving koska going into the endgame of
this raid i was left in a complete tizzy
i honestly couldn't predict what was
going to happen i just knew that i had
to keep reading i'm just so unbelievably
invested in these characters and what
little can be salvaged of guts and
casca's relationship that i honestly
felt like the worst was on the horizon
for them miura had already demonstrated
his ability to drag these characters
down to depths i never before
anticipated and so he had me primed
expecting the very same this time around
too so much has gone wrong for guts in
this series he's lost almost everything
and kaska could be i think perhaps the
final nail in the coffin for him which i
think went a very long way towards
cultivating that love i have for
isidro's character kaska is on the
stakes ready to be burned alive courtesy
of father musgus hate that guy guts is
nowhere to be seen and otherwise trying
and failing to get there on time and
just as i was resigned to yet another
person in god's life being taken away
from him for reasons he would no doubt
blame himself for isidro drops from the
heavens and hoists her up into the air
when this happened i literally ran
straight to my fiance and said you see
that kid he's awesome to which she said
mark it's 6 a.m i'm trying to sleep we
have a great relationship this climax
honestly has it all and miura doesn't
let us down in the artistic department
either not one bit depicting father
mosgos as an angelic figure of divinity
there to protect the refugees only made
me fall in love with this character more
than i already have and what's more was
that the brilliant touch miura gave to
his character once he strips himself
down to nothing but pure plates and
muscle his primary attack is a
bludgeoning barrage of blunt strikes
there to represent a heretic stoning
he's the judge jury and executioner and
miura has done everything to create a
final battle between himself and guts to
rival many of the battles we've seen in
the past it's brilliant honestly i
mentioned before how farenese denies the
ugly reality of the world she lives in
by doing nothing and constantly saying
to herself that everything is still the
same her entire identity and sanity is
built upon her religion by experiencing
the true force of the world in its most
terrifying form to the most
heartbreaking forms by moscow's turning
into one of those semi-apostles she
finally finds something real in all of
this guts standing alone never breaking
and always fighting back against this
chaotic reality check even in her
confusion when she almost drops her
torch and begins praying to her already
proven non-existent faith lying to
herself for the last time it's guts much
like he did with jill in the previous
arc who helps her find the courage to
fight back and take action by not
depending and waiting for things to
magically resolve by themselves but
instead through her own power farnese
picks up her torch and for the first
time she struggles against this cruel
reality and she decides to follow guts
and seek the answers to all of her
questions by looking at the real world
without clinging to false hopes or idols
followed by her loyal servant serpico
similar to isidro i honestly cannot wait
to see where this gang goes together
with guts in the future and it's not
just this the real story of this arc has
been guts trying everything in his power
to right the wrongs he's made and
reconnect with koska to find her and to
protect her in her current state and at
numerous instances whether that be the
refugee camp the cultist gathering and
the rate of the castle there's always
been something to prevent him from
protecting her stopping him from staying
by the side of the one person he loves
more than anyone
which brings me to the ending and while
i absolutely adore this section more
than anything i've read in a very long
time i mean i think i even like this
more than the best parts of the golden
age while i was writing this it became
abundantly apparent to me that the video
was either going to be too short to talk
about this ending properly or it was
going to be too long to edit in a single
week for my editor i really don't like
splitting up arcs this much and so we
came up with what i think will be a good
compromise the next berserk review will
be falcon of the millennium empire arc
part 1. but in addition to my coverage
of that material i will also chat about
the ending of this arc in the detail it
deserves so next time you're getting a
super review and judging by the bit of
the arc that i have read i think this is
going to flow really well there's been a
heavy emphasis on the themes of fate and
causality through this story which in
some ways sort of conflict with each
other and now that the armies are
marching griffith is flying away on his
big buff zod boy and guts is riding off
into the dawn with casca i have no
friggin idea where this story is going
to take me and the best part is i'm only
halfway through this series what does
get me excited though is that isidro
lady farnese and serpico are following
closely behind guts and casca and in a
way this sort of makes me feel like
they're building towards their very own
brand of the hawk 2.0 right now and i
love all the characters present for it i
really hope the falcon of the millennium
empire arc will be as good as conviction
has been but there's only one way to
find out guys tune in next time when i
cover that arc and if you don't want to
miss it leave a like and subscribe for
more but until then i've been totally
not mark i'll see you all next time and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
yes